my favorite call that I have ever made I  try to make it about the athletes and  not so much myself but certainly the  Leon Edwards finish comes to mind and  obviously a narrative in that fight had  become maybe the moral victory for Leon  and it was late in the fight and I felt  like that narrative had gotten trotted  out again and I just sort of felt like I  had to interject like yeah but that's  just not the cloth from which this guy  is cut and then of course the head kick  happened shortly thereafter better to be  lucky than good obviously as a  broadcaster but you know I'm pretty  proud of the championship cause when  we've been able to acknowledge you know  yamahovich polander guy got it done  certainly when Brandon Moreno broke  through for Tijuana I try to have each  call be unique to the moment and uh  obviously some have been better than  others sometimes we miss like the big  knockouts and then you just have to say  oh and then look at the replay and see  what happened